here we go everybody from timcast.com
SNL staff writers boycotting this
weekend's episode over Dave Chappelle
hosting according to report there you go
that's about it they're not going to do
the show an unnamed Insider told the
outlet but none of the actors are
boycotting so the uh they say quote the
room was full of writers they all
pitched ideas and they seemed very
excited about it Dave is looking to have
some fun so there uh that was a rep from
uh Chappelle saying there's nothing
going on but uh I don't know what do you
guys think they want they want to try
and cancel Dave Chappelle well this
story first came from an anonymous
source that again came out didn't reveal
who or she uh was and said oh we're
going to be boycotting
um Dave Chappelle and his staff are
saying hey we've been working with the
writers and the actors for the last
three days nothing's changed no one's
really boycotting us so I think this is
just like the kind of Netflix protest
that we saw of Dave Chappelle where the
media was hyping it up saying there's
going to be thousands of people there
and they were blasting it trying to make
it seemed like it was a bigger cause and
a bigger reality than it actually was I
think this is also the same thing where
you have this kind of engineering of
this Viewpoint gaslighting people to
make them believe that people are
outraged against Dave Chappelle when in
reality Dave Chappelle is a comedy
genius and what he's done especially
with his stories about about trans
people has actually been kind of an
advocacy for them rather than a
criticism of it specifically when he
talked about his friend so for him to
get criticized for this is absolutely
absurd I don't think anyone's trying to
boycott him and if you are trying to
boycott a comedian for for telling jokes
you're taking life too seriously and
you're full of crap listen there you
know again Lenny Bruce and George Carlin
the likes of those they went to jail
over obscenity laws back in the 50s and
60s it's a damn shame that these things
are happening right now
there's two places in America you should
when you walk in the door you should
expect to be a little bit offended or at
least be made uncomfortable once the
church the other is the comedy show
right both of them have been watered
down so bad you know the comedy show
they're afraid to offend anybody uh the
they're they're afraid to tell jokes I
tell everybody when I get on stage it's
like look I don't care if you gay
straight black white fat skinny male
female trans Z gym her I don't care what
you are if I'm gonna make fun of myself
75 percent of the time I get to make fun
of you too ridicule is part of the job
you should be able to do that doesn't
mean you hate people doesn't mean you're
mad at people doesn't mean you wanna you
said this earlier they've never suffered
no they never have they know the way I
describe it is you know I'm sure
everybody in this room has gotten
physically hurt to some degree these are
people who live in pastel you know
beanbag rooms it was it was a university
I remember 10 years ago whatever they
created safe space rooms where if a
lecture was offensive you can go in
those bean bags and fluffy animals so if
these people have never actually fallen
and scraped their knee or anything like
that when someone says you're dumb they
go
yeah it's the worst pain they've ever
experienced yeah on 60 Minutes this past
Sunday night they had the interviewer of
course was talking to a college
professor and he said how do you deal
with these tough topics he goes you
don't bring them up and he said but
isn't that what the university setting
is all about he goes it used to be
now you can't discuss to listen our
country was founded on the ability to
dialogue disagree debate discuss all of
these different things and fight I mean
John Adams in in Thomas Jefferson at
least if you read their writings they
hated each other yeah right and that was
okay they were still considered the
founding fathers and we we're supposed
to be able to do that and then come back
to this thing called the Constitution
and the Bill of Rights it says okay this
is what brings us together you might say
something that pisses me off but at the
end of the day that's okay I listen my
father used to tell me all the time
talking about one of my brothers he said
yeah he's full of [ __ ] but if you listen
to him long enough every now you might
find a pearl in the middle of it well
more importantly that's a very important
takeaway there sorry that's all good
just made me think of my brother and I'm
full of [ __ ] he is
um but but another thing that's very
important to note here is that comedy
heals a division in our society and when
you outlaw comedy when you make people
afraid to express comedy you perpetuate
a society where it's impossible to heal
any division in it and I think this is
why we're seeing such delay deliberate
actions against comedians against people
trying to make other people laugh
against people trying to bring people
together and this is just upsurge to see
Dave Chappelle attacked so much where he
even has to get serious during his
comedy special and address all this
nonsense I don't want to see that I want
to see him roll with the punches I want
to see him address a lot of the critics
by making fun of them and I think even
he was someone who is is an
anti-establishment guy who is seen as as
a Critic of society said okay now we
have to get serious during this comedy
special and I'm gonna have to address
this seriously I I hate it to see that I
thought it was a capitulation and I
think they're trying to limit his
expression and limit everyone's
expression because he's the canary in
the coal mine right now but I do think
you're right I think that's all smoke
mirrors and I don't think anybody's
complaining about it like just like the
divisiveness in this country when you
see your neighbor across the street
you're not fighting in the street it
really does come from the media they're
like well what do I want them to fight
about this weekend
I love that screen grab are you sitting
there holding that bottle of wine
fantastic shot right there uh but you're
right about that I mean nothing unifies
people should comedy and music should
bring people together I mean listen you
take Jim Jeffries right Jim Jeffery's
Australian he he's everything I'm not
politically uh he goes on these long
binges about the the Second Amendment
how we shouldn't have guns and stuff it
I disagree with him 100 but I laughed my
ass off when I hear him do it because
it's funny because I first of all I've
got tough skin I I can disagree with
somebody and still laugh at what you're
saying you know you're not trying you're
not legislating me into something you're
trying to make me laugh yeah let's put
it in perspective here they roast me in
the comments all the time I love it I
saw that I saw it I was like damn and
it's and it's fine and it's okay because
I understand like hey this is this is
the landscape I'm gonna I'm still going
to express myself I'm not going to let
these comments affect me but at the same
time I know a lot of it is trolling and
trying to make me laugh and trying to
engage and and and it's totally
acceptable it's totally okay and if and
and everyone should be okay with
criticism everyone should be okay with
people uh you know saying something
about them constructive criticism I
think is one of the most important
things in our society that is needed
more than ever and we don't have a lot
of that at all people are afraid of any
kind of criticism people are afraid of
any kind of responsibility and I think
we should normalize a society where you
could speak truth to power but that
right there is being eliminated from our
society and it sucks yeah
I saw the comments a second ago they
said CJ was in her 20s and I'm in my 50s
I'm liking this ratio
[Laughter]
they think I'm in my 20s yeah several of
them said make sure you keep the jacket
off it's fantastic I think you're making
that up right now I'm in the comments uh
yeah I I I don't think he's lying he he
makes up a lot that's okay go with it
I'm drinking tequila you can talk call
me 20 any days hey girl
but yeah love you guys
it's awesome to be a part of the
conversation what would we do without
those folks exactly we need people like
that yeah and if you're gonna criticize
me I know they're going to criticize
everybody else good we need that
critical thing you know I had people you
free I've always been a whatever
creative person I come up with Goofy
things all the time and people used to
say to me and it was the number one
phrase you have too much time on your
hands now now I joke and I say yeah I
got time to stand in line at the bank to
make deposits but you take Dave
Chappelle Dave Chappelle
is eating it up like I I've met Dave
Dave's a super nice guy I mean he's a
real person and you know
when you got Netflix paying you 70
million dollars to do an hour and you go
out there and you tape over four nights
however many he's doing two to four
nights to do this special and the bad
press sure you want everybody to like
you but they don't and as a comedian you
know it's like being in sales you're
going to be told no 65 of the time 75
percent of the time this guy's worked in
crowds that hate his guts don't want to
laugh at him and so when the woke mom
comes after him
you know I talk about this in my book uh
am I crazy which talks about you know
living in a woke world and being
Unapologetic in the middle of it the
beauty of Dave Chappelle is the beauty
of Bill Burr the beauty of a Jim
Jefferies even on that side of things
they're Unapologetic yeah and that's an
extremely attractive thing in every
career path you take once you're saying
and doing things just to be liked you
become pathetic that's exactly and if
you're not questioning things if you're
not pushing the needle if you're not
pushing the envelope you're doing
something wrong when it comes to having
a conversation and I think that's what
we should all strive to do uh that's
see-through yeah it's it's obvious yeah
last week or whenever it was Luke Bryan
he's doing he's doing a show in Florida
he brings Rhonda Santos on stage The
Crowd Goes Nuts and then of course the
online rereads go nuts you're saying oh
my God I can't believe you brought this
guy on he responds and said when I'm in
a state that's been hit by a hurricane
been devastated for me to bring the
governor on to help these people I was
raised to do that right and it was my
paraphrase and I was like don't don't
apologize
don't effing apologize don't you do it
like when Joe Rogan apologized don't
apologize that's an admission of guilt
they sense weakness and they're gonna
pounce it don't do it you just admitted
guilt it's blood in the water yeah 100
and that's why that's why our brand you
know everything Unapologetic Beyond
apologetic always and and I'm not saying
you did something wrong yeah to somebody
personally you insulted them or you hurt
them yeah go apologize that's not what
I'm saying I'm talking about the culture
at Large
own the Tweet own the [ __ ] you said and
just move forward
yeah absolutely it's kind of sad you
know because apologies are supposed to
be it's a good thing it's it's it's
mature you recognize you did something
wrong you say you know what I I'll own
up to that yeah but what's happened now
is they've exploited our Goodwill to to
such a degree that now it's like yeah
you're better off just not yeah they've
abused the better angels and so like if
if this group if I say something stupid
which I'm apt to do if I say something
stupid and then and then we go
downstairs and Tim comes to me
individually and says dude that pissed
me off and I'm like hey I'm sorry man
I'm sorry that pissed you off I didn't
mean to piss you off that's one thing
but you know it for me to come back in
and bring you guys all back in the room
and say look I made this off the cuff
statement that I don't even know if you
heard it I need to apologize to all of
you I just made you aware of [ __ ] you
didn't even know you were aware of you
didn't even know if you heard it right
when you do that to culture at large
you're shooting yourself in the foot in
a big way now you're gonna you're gonna
have a tattoo on you for the rest of
your life you're marked yep you just
told everybody that you hear the apology
but they never saw the original they
weren't offended in the first place you
had to tell them they were offended yeah
that's what's wrong with our culture
right now you
were talking about uh Jerry Jones the
owner of the Dallas Cowboys who goes for
Halloween he dresses up like a blind
referee and whatever the association
Confederation whatever it is the United
World of blind people is pissed off and
they want something they want an apology
and I'm like how the F did they know he
dressed up they're blind how did they
know yeah so what he dressed up as for
Halloween
yeah somebody had to tell them to be
offended yeah
that's a good costume the point is he's
a referee who couldn't make a good call
like it's a good joke why didn't the
referees Association get pissed off yeah
seriously they have more right to him
they do they saw it
throw the flag man I don't know the way
things are going I'll just say
watch
these people have no principles and uh
it's exemplified by movies like black
panther 2.
because if I could explain what the
movie was about and spoil it it's just
like the ultimate hypocrisy you should
do among these what
you should spoil it maybe I'll spoil it
in the after show for those that I mean
the movie literally just came out you
know what I mean we went and saw the
early showing we do it because one I'm a
big fan of the Marvel movies I actually
thought the story was was enjoyable
that's not the best but uh man was that
movie racist and they and the same thing
with the first one too it's like they
everything they claimed look
these cancel culture people they're not
offended they're not even offended they
just they're just bored online and it's
something to do and it makes them feel
powerful or part of something yeah if
they were offended they would watch
Black Panther too and be like yo we
better boycott this moment they're not
there's like the whole thing is just
insulting Mexican people thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time